el presidente de eeuu ha invitado a su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin a celebrar
una cumbre en un tercer país para
estabilizar las relaciones bilaterales
de una vez
el kremlin responde ahora que es
prematuro hablar en términos tangibles
sobre una posible reunión entre ambos
mandatarios es cierto que hay muchas
heridas que cerrar rusia se llevó a
moscú a su embajador cuando baiden llamo
asesinó a putin en una entrevista las
canciones además contra rusia se siguen
acumulando y un informe de inteligencia
de eeuu considera a rusia como la
principal amenaza en cuanto a armas de
destrucción masiva en su llamada bailén
también pidió a putin reducir las
tensiones en ucrania pero estados unidos
ha enviado barcos de guerra al mar negro
y que ha hecho rusia ha recomendado a
los norteamericanos mantener sus buques
lo más alejado posible de las costas de
rusia en el mar negro particularmente
las de crimea mosco advierte del alto
riesgo de incidentes el crem insiste la
des escalada de tensiones en el este de
ucrania sólo será posible si quiere
renunciar a las provocaciones